mes chers amis républicains chers jeunes
républicains vous savez le président de
la république a décidé de faire des
reconnaissances aériennes au dessus de
la syrie
mais nous en france on serait rentrés
heureux qu'ils atterrissent
parce que voyez vous depuis son arrivée
au pouvoir
dès qu'il a eu un problème à régler il
l'a transformée en catastrophe que ce
soit effectivement le chômage la famille
la sécurité la justice même
l'organisation territoriale
à chaque fois le résultat a été
dramatique pour notre pays mais assez
catastrophe s'ajoute une succession de
mensonges
au point que l'on pourrait parler dans
notre pays deux républiques des
mensonges et d'un état l'état d'abandon
mensonge à bandeau amateurisme
amateurisme on l'a encore vu cette
semaine sur la fermeture de fessenheim
sur la sphère de la non livraison des
mistral des mistral à la russie sur la
soi-disant baisse des impôts sur la
baisse du chômage sur la baisse du
chômage
le président françois hollande ne pourra
se targuer d'avoir fait baisser le
chômage que lorsqu'il sera au moins
revenu aux chiffres qui était celui de
mai 2012 lorsque il est arrivé au
pouvoir mais certainement pas avoir le
culot de nous dire avec quelques
mesurettes ou avec quelques petits
trafics otage dans le comptage
malheureusement des chômeurs eh bien on
arrive à faire croire qu'il pourrait y
avoir une baisse à l'évidence mes chers
amis le président de la république est à
l'image du socialisme du socialisme
malade il a trop duré
oui mais devant tout cela c'est à nous
qu'incombe rae aux jeunes qu'incombera
la tâche de redresser la france
et de réaffirmer ses valeurs des valeurs
qui ont été tellement bafoués on l'a dit
aujourd'hui tant de fois bien sûr la
famille
qui est au coeur de nos préoccupations
parce qu'elle constitue un socle les
valeurs du travail
synonyme démenti d'émancipation
d'épanouissement les valeurs de
responsabilité de liberté de sécurité
d'autorité comment accepter dans le nord
qu'il y a quelle il y a quelques
semaines à peine que l'autoroute puisse
être pendant des heures et des heures
bloqué pour quelques motifs que ce soit
en prenant en otage des milliers
d'automobilistes l'état socialiste est
un état à l'abandon et les valeurs
d'éducation de l'école les valeurs
d'humanisme ne sont pas en réalité
l'apanage des socialistes qui sont des
calculateurs invétéré les valeurs
d'humanisme nous ne savons les les
combinés si je puis dire
avec également le réalisme et c'est tout
le sens des propos de nicolas sarkozy
lorsqu'il a pris la parole avec beaucoup
de pertinence
sur cette question des migrants qui
préoccupe chacun d'entre nous et qui
n'en est qu'à son début
alors je dis effectivement jeunes
réinvestissent et le terrain des valeurs
mais également je voudrais vous dire
vous les jeunes qui avaient fait un
travail formidable pour préparer ce
campus et que j'admire beaucoup
investissez vous dans la politique
investissez vous pour la défense des
valeurs effective en mai investi c'est
aussi le champ des idées vous les jeunes
investissent et le champ de l'innovation
donnez nous des raisons d'espérer fait
rêver la france croyait profondément
qu'un avenir est possible
l'air dans laquelle nous vivons est une
succession de révolution industrielle
qui font rebondir l'économie
pratiquement tous les cinq ans les
révolutions industrielles que nous vos
parents ou ceux qui nous ont précédés
ont connu s'étaler sur des périodes bien
plus longue de 30 ans au moins
alors profitons de cette chance
aujourd'hui en créant l'environnement
propice à l'éclosion de cette nouvelle
économie de cet écosystème nouveau qu'il
faut bâtir l'internet et je le dis ici
devant nathalie qui connaît par coeur ce
sujet accélère la création c'est un
levier extraordinaire pour l'emploi et
la croissance
c'est également une chance pour notre
région dans laquelle nous pouvons croire
à nouveau parce que je le sais j'en suis
certain quand je vois l'énergie le
talent la campagne extraordinaire qu'il
fait demain xavier bertrand à la tête de
notre région nous donnera de vraies
raisons d'espérer
hier c'était on peut l'applaudir xavier
fait une campagne formidable et avec
gérald darmanin son directeur de cabinet
et toute l'équipe qui est qui a été
réuni autour de lui
oui cette nouvelle économie qui est en
marche est une chance qu'il faut saisir
dans notre région du nord hier c'était
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui ce sont
les objets connectés et les deux
amplifie les succès se font écho l'un à
l'autre je voudrais que vous les jeunes
foncier dans cet univers propulsant
notre économie et notre région en
position de leader européen
cette french tech comme on dit qui s'est
allié création design web électronique
la france a des filières universitaires
sensationnel formidable et reconnu et ce
n'est pas daniel fasquelle que je vais
la prendre lui qui a dans ce domaine une
très grande expertise
il faut regrouper toutes ses compétences
pour les transformer en succès
industriel c'est-à-dire en emploi pour
vous c'est le vrai projet au coeur de la
préoccupation de xavier bertrand
je vous dis cela car je crois dans les
ressources de la france je crois dans sa
jeunesse
je crois en vous mes chers amis je crois
dans nos leaders également au sein des
républicains c'est parce qu'ils ne sont
pas tous pareils que notre parti est
riche de sa diversité
créatif et qu'il peut rassembler le plus
grand nombre
arrêtons d'emmerder les français disait
georges pompidou
en 1966 il poursuivait il y a trop de
textes trop de règlements dans ce pays
on en crève laisser vivre un peu les
français et vous verrez que tout ira
mieux
foutez leur la paix disait-il il faut
libérer le pays
cette phrase est toujours d'actualité
libérons notre pays
héron notre région alors mes amis merci
à vous la jeunesse et au travail